[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
- OKAY, MAN, YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT WASN'T MY FAULT, ALL RIGHT?
I-I-I-I HAD THE MONEY
LIKE YOU SAID
IN A TRASH BAG
IN THE BACK OF MY CAR,
AND I WAS GONNA GO
STRAIGHT TO THE DROP SPOT.
ALL RIGHT?
NO, NO--HOL--OKAY.
OKAY, OKAY.
OKAY, NO--NO, HEY,
HEY, HEY, HEY, MAN.
THERE AIN'T NO NEED FOR YOU
TO GET COMFORTABLE.
OKAY? BECAUSE--BECAUSE
I'M TELLING YOU, MAN.
WHAT HAPPENED
WASN'T MY FAULT, ALL RIGHT?
I-I-I-I-I-I DROVE TO
THE AGREED UPON LOCATION, MAN.
OH--OH, MAN.
WHAT?
OKAY--OKAY, OKAY!
OKAY, BEC--BEC--OKAY.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO NEED
TO HAVE ANYTHING CRAZY
IN A PAPER BAG.
I'M TELLING YOU.
THERE'S AN EXPLANATION
FOR WHAT WENT DOWN!
WHOA! WHOA!
WHOA! WHOA! OKAY!
LET'S CALM DOWN NOW.
LET'S CALM DOWN, MAN.
THERE AIN'T NO NEED.
OH, A JUICE BOX?
THERE AIN'T NO NEED
TO EAT A MEAL
AND THEN DO
SOME CRAZY [bleep]
WITH THE PLASTIC
SANDWICH CONTAINER!
OH, MAN, COME ON.
COME ON, MAN.
JUST CHILL OUT A LITTLE BIT.
JUST--YOU NEED
TO RELAX, MAN.
YOU NEED TO
TAKE IT EASY AND RELA--
OH, [bleep]!
OH, GODDAMN!
NOW, COME ON, MAN!
DON'T DO IT, DON'T DO IT!
DON'T DO IT, MAN! YOU SH--
COME ON, MAN.
OH, YOU'RE EATING THE SANDWICH!
YOU'RE EATING THE SANDWICH.
[sobbing]
OH, MAN, HOW YOU GONNA
SANDWICH ME, DOG?
HOW YOU GONNA SANDWICH ME?
OH, [bleep]!
OKAY, LOOK,
IT'S GETTIN' CRAZY NOW!
IT'S GOTTA STOP!
IT'S GOTTA STOP RIGHT NOW, OKAY?
YOU CLEANIN' YOURSELF UP BEFORE
YOU DO SOME ILL [bleep]?
COME ON, MAN!
WHAT YOU DOIN'?
WHAT YOU WANNA KNOW?
WHAT--I'LL TELL YOU
WHATEVER YOU WANNA KNOW, MAN!
JUST PLEASE STOP
THIS COLD-ASS [bleep], MAN!
I'M BEGGIN' YOU,
DOG, PLEASE.
OH, [bleep]! NO! NO, OKAY!
LOOK, OKAY, MAY--MAYBE IT WAS
MY FAULT A LITTLE BIT.
MAYBE IT WAS MY FAULT
A LITTLE BIT, BUT DON'T JUST--
WHAT YOU GONNA DO
WITH THAT JUICE BOX, MAN?
WHAT'RE YOU GONNA
DO WITH THAT J--
DO WITH THE STRAW?
WHAT'RE YOU GONNA
COME ON, MAN, DO--
LISTEN, LISTEN.
NO, NO. NO, I DID IT! I DID IT!
I DID IT, OKAY? I DID IT!
I DID IT, I LEFT THE CAR!
I LEFT FOR THREE MINUTES!
SO PLEASE DON'T DO ANYTHING
WITH THE STRAW!
WHY AREN'T YOU STOPPING?
FINE! FINE!
AAH!
[screams]
AAH! MAN!
OKAY, MAN!
HA, HA! I BEAT YOU TO IT!
OKAY? I GOT YOUR POINT,
ALL RIGHT, MAN?
HA!
OH, MAN, THAT'S A BITCH!
[muffled screaming]
[beeping]
- WILL WE BE HAVING ANY MORE
PROBLEMS OUT OF HIM, SIR?
- [tiny voice]
NO.
- YEAH. THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKIN' ABOUT.